captain's daddy went down with his ship
so who has the Conn Gator I believe you
do sir call of duty infinite warfare is
taking this series to new heights and
those Heights our outer space we've
learned a lot about the game's new take
on multiplayer loadouts and the zombies
mode but now we've gotten a solid handle
on the story thanks to a new trailer
this is infinite warfare and this is
what we know so why are we in space when
earth's resources run low there's only
one place to start looking for new
sustenance and that happens outside of
our atmosphere but open space also means
open opportunities for insurgencies to
rise up and that's where the settlement
Defense front comes into play the SDF is
run by Admiral salen Koch played by a
game of thrones star Kit Harington
you may have already heard that but did
you know UFC fighter Conor McGregor is
also in the game he plays captain
Bradley Fillion and he will punch you in
the face of Admiral Koch orders it the
SDF attacks settlements both on earth
and in space leaving just two allied
ships in orbit you'll play is captain
Nick Reyes who assumes control of one of
those ships the retribution serving at
his side is lieutenant Norris alter
played by Tru Bloods Jamie gray Haider
the retribution serves as a hub world
where you can take on side ops in
addition to the main campaign missions
these will encompass both aerial and
boots on the ground combat and what
Activision calls a quote classic war
story of course you'll also spend plenty
of time and space a not so classic
theater of war call of duty infinite
warfare launches on ps4 xbox one and pc
on november fourth and remember if you
want to get the remastered version of
call of duty 4 modern warfare it's only
included with special editions of the
game if you want to check out more
trailers or learn about infinite
Warfare's new multiplayer rigs head on
over to gamespot
you